and that lineup will face this rookie
left-hander daniel lynch would be a
seventh start on the season you can see
his numbers are kind of
a little bit across the board uh a
little bumpy here and there three home
runs giving up those six starts and a
little deeper dive in our pitcher
scouting report he is the royals top
pitching prospect and
he was a first round compensation pick
in 2018 out of virginia dj lemayo
he had a triple and a double in the game
last night and he chops one towards
short nice hop
nikki lopez throw to first
is in time so one away three balls one
strike
in the pitch low and inside ball four
daniel lynch
fighting his control a bit here in the
first inning brings up aaron judge
last night judge hit a go-ahead rbi
single and now lynch the 2-2
swinging a miss so a fastball up
aaron judge could not resist
swinging a miss for out number two
salvi's setting up inside but didn't
necessarily need to go in there he got
the swing of the miss up and away
so now daniel lynch sees his first
left-handed batter
and a slider buckled him you got him
with a breaking ball gallow could not
pull the trigger and lynch after the
one-out walk gets two straight
strikeouts the yankees secret weapon
nestor cortez on the bump in
kansas city tonight you can see on the
season
12 games in the four starts this will be
his fifth start the numbers are great
across the board and a little more of a
look in the scouting report the fearless
fastball i mean he really does have good
command it's up a couple of ticks on
velocity and opposing batters are six
for 62 and 0.97 batting average against
off of that fastball he's tough on
righties
and a line drive into right center field
classic whitmer field and he's on to
begin the first so hitless last night
but not tonight this is a memorable date
for salvador perez as he comes up with
one on and one out there goes wit and
it's swung on and belted
deep left center field and gone
ten years to the day that he made his
big league debut
and on this date salvador perez has a
new career high 28 home runs oh man it
was a no doubter whit was running on the
pitch early and he just kind of stopped
at second and watched it sail out he
didn't even think about going back to
first base because he knew nice warm
humid day slight breeze blowing to left
field and salvador perez could take him
out of the yard and he did
andrew benintendi after the first pitch
slicer up the left field line and fair
and into the corner and ben and tendy at
second base with a double the royals
have a single a two run home run and a
double in the first inning against
nestor cortes 100 second two out two
runs in the left-handers next pitch is
on the outside corner strike three
called
and that's the inning but merrifield
singles perez homers
once again the 2-2
and the fastball is hit in the air to
left-center on the run is davis to make
a one-hand running catch
i don't know how much he'll hit but he
can play center field
so
kansas city has denied a run no run
one hit one error
velazquez drives that to center field
taylor back can't make the play it's
over his head and off the wall
andrew velazquez with his first hit as a
yankee he has a one out double this ball
is hammered
see the two-seam grip right there kind
of running away stays middle away
and that's drilled to center field
taylor is back he's got that one
velasquez
was not tagging now he does is taylor
heaves it all the way to third base
taylor's had some pretty good distance
with his throws in this inning and a
two-out opportunity for john carlos
stanton that one skips away from perez
velazquez will score and how impactful
was his base running now 2-1 game as
velazquez helps create that run with his
wheels back-to-back change-ups this one
he spikes
stan grounds one through the left side a
two-out single for giancarlo stanton
stanton rolls over it but finds the hole
there's the 2-2
swung on and missed struck him out but
the yankees get a run on three hits
on with one out in the fourth here's
kyle higashioka now the 01 is swung on
and hit in the air to left center and
deep that ball's high it is far it is
gone higashi oka the home run stroka he
drills a two run home run to deep left
center field and he's getting piggy with
it and the yankees now take a 3-2 lead
watch kakashioka's eyes light up he
knows he got it right off the bat boyd
works a walk and now the bases are
loaded for ruben o'dorr
the pitch from tapia swing and a miss he
struck him out change-up had him out in
front and the royals are off the hook
after the bases were loaded all via the
walk so we go to the home fifth inning
at kauffman stadium 1-0 on width the
pitch and he'll swing and line that into
right center four ahead it's in the gap
it's gonna roll for a while extra bases
for whitmer field he's gonna cruise into
second with a two out double so he's in
scoring position second hit of the night
who is playing in his 419th consecutive
game has
142 multi-hit games in the batter nikki
lopez 0 for two will stand in nick he's
hit in five straight games
whit takes off for third breaking ball
is a strike throw down gets away from
the third baseman goes down the left
field line here comes with to score the
tying run tied 3-3
stolen base number 32 for whit
merrifield 32 in a row he comes home on
a throwing error by the catcher
higashiyoka the mayhew came through with
an rbi double in the 11th inning last
night
lines that into right field to base it
not a strong arm does dozier have davis
with plenty of speed and the yankees
take a 4-3 lead on an rbi single from dj
le mayhew how about salvi today fizzy
homer's in the first inning maybe he'll
do it here it's the 10th anniversary of
his call up in 2011. he's the pitch and
there's a swing and a high drive deep to
left racing back stanton he is at the
fence and that ball is out of here
salvador perez ties the game with his
second home run of the night
what a reunion night for salvador perez
that's a heck of an anniversary party to
homer twice on your 10th anniversary
ridings with the 1-2 and that ball is
drilled in the gap left center field
that ball is going to get to the wall
rivera's got a hustle around third he's
coming home and he will score the go
ahead to third as dozier he is out but
the royals take the lead on the double
by dozier
alberto has been picking things up and
twice he struck the ball sharply
look out the play is to first oh it's
gonna
get past lemay here the royals will add
a run
and they'll get another 90 feet and
rioting really has had a poor start
against his old ball club
and there's the bunt
the play is the first and it's just in
time but the run is home the safety
squeeze was executed perfectly by nikki
lopez and the royals go in front seven
to four now hands are alberto he is over
two all four infielders in for the play
at the plate and a line shot into center
field that's going to score ben and
tindy from third the other runners will
stay put zavarlo has reduced the game
down to run out
and the royals
even the series in come from behind
fashion